the game rewards are over so here are
the top seven announcements from the
show for starters cyberpunk 2077's
Phantom Liberty expansion got a new
trailer that revealed actor Idris Alba
will play Solomon Reed and FIA agent for
the nusa how cool is that the game went
from being the butt of many jokes to
having a cool anime and a surge of
players to grabbing another major
Hollywood actors to play a character I'm
impressed but not as impressed as I was
watching the gameplay premiere for Star
Wars Jedi Survivor in the trailer we get
to see an older more grizzled cow kestus
and his new heightened Jedi abilities
that include a new lightsaber stance
where he wields two Sabers at once for
quick hard-hitting offense a new
Mobility option grappling hook Cal
riding different animals fighting
alongside a companion and holding a kylo
ren style saber we also got confirmation
of survivors March 17th release date
following a couple of leak rumors
earlier this week another game with a
confirmed release date is Final Fantasy
16. the game got a brand new trailer and
the official date of June 22nd the
trailer showed off more of the
fast-paced action that we've seen in
previous trailers as well as a glimpse
of espers the player will be able to
find throughout their Adventure the
horseback riding esper appears to be
Odin while a new demonic one is seen
attacking hero Clive rossfield later in
the trailer rossfield summons an esper
of his own and uses it in battle but
those aren't the only giant things we
saw fighting from software announced
armored Core 6 fires of Rubicon at the
show the brief teaser showed a ruined
World followed by some glimmer shots of
big Stompy robots as well as other giant
mechanized behemoths which is what you
would want from a Mecca game
unfortunately but also fortunately there
was no date given to that game the same
can be he said about Hades 2 which was
announced yesterday as well unlike the
first Hades game Hades 2 follows a
female protagonist who is zagreus's
sister and is called the princess of the
Underworld the trailer opens with her
training with a masked mentor and it's
reveal that their joint objective is to
kill Kronos this announcement instantly
made me feel guilty for not beating the
first Hades and caused me to dust off my
digital copy AKA I re-downloaded it on
my switch so far part 2 is only
confirmed for PC but is planned for
consoles as well supergiant says it will
share more information about
availability on other platforms at a
later date one place you probably won't
see Hades too is mobile luckily vampire
survivors got a surprise release on IOS
and Android yesterday for free it's only
five dollars on other platforms but why
not grab it on your phone and lose even
more hours of your life to it when those
platforms aren't around you that could
be a great way to waste time while you
wait for DS2 no not that DS2 I'm talking
about death stranding too Kojima himself
appeared on stage at the game awards to
Hype up the game saying the announcement
trailer was filled with secrets about
the project that fans can dig into as
they await new information he also
revealed the story for death stranding
two was written before the covet
pandemic but the onset of the pandemic
caused Kojima to rewrite the script
entirely make sure you keep an eye out
for our breakdowns because we're gonna
dive deeper into those Secrets Kojima
mentioned so what's your favorite moment
or announcement from the 2022 game
awards let us know in the comments below
foreign